IAN ELLISON TAYLOR:
Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I want to thank everyone who
made it down to Mountain View.
It looks like we got a pretty
packed house tonight.
That's pretty good.
Hopefully, it wasn't
just for the beer.
And of course, we have
an audience on video
conference from Asia.
I'm assuming they can see us,
since I can't see them.
But anyway, thank
you for coming.
Hopefully, you'll have a fun and
interesting evening about
Native Client.
So to rewind just a little bit,
I think Google's fairly
well known for being a little
bit obsessed about
performance.
And so two, three years ago,
someone posed the question of
what would it be like if we
could run native code inside
the browser?
And that seemed like a really
interesting question, and it
sort of broke down into two main
goals for that, that we
started really investing in.
The first, of course, was how
to bring native applications
to the web in terms of
performance and the power.
But also maintaining what's good
about the web in terms of
security and portability, so
that was goal number one.
Goal number two was really
about enriching the web
ecosystem by bringing a lot
of other programming
languages to the web.
Particularly programming
languages that had been around
and were in popular use,
and had been in popular
use for a long time.
So that started a long road,
and I think it was pretty
entertaining, and we've come
a long way I think in those
three years.
So to talk a little bit more
about the technology and the
goals, I'm going to start with
the technical lead for Native
Client, Brad Chen, come on up.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CHEN: Thank you, Ian.
And thanks to all of
you for coming to
Mountain View this evening.
On the engineering side of this
project, we had two main
problems we needed to solve.
Of course, we had to make Native
Client safe, to protect
users from the kinds of
problems that have
historically been common
with native
applications and native plug-ins.
We were painfully aware of the
history of security issues
that have arisen with
technology, such as NPAPI and
ActiveX, and we were determined
to learn the right
lessons from those systems.
But security alone is not
enough, obviously.
We needed to make a system
that was powerful.
We needed to make a system that
would enable developers
to deliver applications that
were new and exciting, but
that weren't already happening
on the web.
Now, in the three or so years
that have transpired since we
first started the research
project, we've made
significant progress towards
solving these problems. With
our Chrome 14 release, we've
shipped a browser that allows
application developers to ship
real applications using the
Native Client sandbox.
Together with a core set of
Pepper interfaces that support
facilities such as 2D graphics,
real-time audio
playback, URL loading, and
asynchronous messaging with
JavaScript.
And we've really enjoyed seeing
our early adopter
developers deliver vintage
arcade games to Native Client
on the web, by porting
emulators
like MAME and DOSBox.
In our more recent release,
we've actually added some more
ambitious and yet very
important features.
One really key feature is
hardware-accelerated 3D graphics.
This enables developers to
do real-time rendering of
detailed scenes, providing the
kinds of rich interactive
experience that we're all trying
to deliver these days.
We also provide sandbox
local file storage.
This is a critical feature for
developers who want to provide
a really great user experience,
both online and offline.
It enables application
developers to provide
applications that
start quickly.
Because graphics, audio, and
other kinds of application
data are stored once on the
local disk, and so they're
already available the next time
the application starts.
We also provide, in our most
recent releases, dynamic
loading and the popular GNU libc
implementation, making it
that much easier
to port complex
applications to Native Client.
I'd also like to mention
full-screen
mode and mouse capture.
These are critical features
for application developers
that are trying to provide a
truly immersive experience.
The result of all of this is
that today, through Native
Client, application developers
can use native code safely in
Chrome across all popular
desktop operating systems. And
they have access to a rich and
growing set of resources from
the browser.
So with that, I'd like to
introduce Erik Kay.
Erik is an engineering manager
for Native Client, and he's
going to tell us a little bit
more about what this means for
developers and for the web.
Erik.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIK KAY: Thanks, Brad,
and hi everyone.
So you've heard that developers
are now going to be
able to bring their native code
to the web, but what does
that really mean for
the web at large?
Well the first thing is, is that
it means that decades of
native code that's been built,
and the expertise that comes
with it, and those millions of
developers who are experienced
in developing native code, can
now bring that to the web.
It'll now be an easy decision
for them to decide to port
their applications to the web,
because they no longer have to
rewrite them from scratch
in HTML and JavaScript.
There's now no reason why
many desktop and mobile
applications can't also
run on your browser.
We're also going to enable
higher performance computing
on the web.
Now, native code, running in
NaCl will often run multiple
times faster than JavaScript
today, and that's in
single-threaded mode.
But Native Client also has
access to efficient
multi-threading, which means it
can take full advantage of
your multi-core CPUs.
This is going to enable a wide
variety of applications that
weren't possible on
the web before.
Now, it's going to do this while
maintaining the security
model of the web today.
Now the main reason for this
is the sandbox that Brad
mentioned earlier.
But it's also because of our
philosophy and what kind of
APIs that we've brought
to Native Client.
Unlike previous technologies,
like NPAPI and ActiveX, we're
not bringing new capabilities
to the web.
Instead, what we're bringing
is the web capabilities to
Native Code.
Now this means that Native Code
will run with the same
security level as JavaScript.
Now we believe the applications
you're going to
see tonight are going to
demonstrate the real need for
this technology.
It's bringing applications
that were never before
possible on the web.
And as such, we think it's
important for this technology
to not be limited to
a single browser.
We've developed Native Client
from the beginning in the
public as an open source
project, and are committed to
working with other browser
vendors to
bring it to all users.
We work closely with the open
source community, accepting
external contributions, and
we're looking forward to
continuing that close
relationship.
Now that's what it means for
the web, but what about for
developers?
Well, one of the big problems
developers have today is that
there are so many platforms
out there.
You're having to develop for
Windows, for Mac, maybe iOS,
and Android, maybe a game
console, then there's the web.
This often involves you having
to maintain multiple
development teams, multiple
code bases--
trying to keep them all in
sync is a very expensive
proposition.
With Native Client, you're now
going to be able to leverage
your existing code base,
and quickly and easily
bring it to the web.
We've seen already developers
bring million line code bases
to Native Client, in just a
couple of weeks and a handful
of developers.
And that's including the time
necessary to just learn the
technology to begin with.
Now, for many developers, the
best part is going to be the
fact that now on the web you're
going to be able to use
your favorite programming
language.
You don't need to
learn new stuff.
You can leverage your existing
knowledge, your existing
tools, your existing technology
that you've spent
so much time and effort
investing in.
And further, it's important to
remember that development is
not just about writing code,
it's also about the
tools behind it.
You have build systems, testing,
revision control--
all of these systems will work
seamlessly with your existing
code base and Native Client.
So once you've built your
application, you need to
distribute it.
We're here to help
with that too.
Today, you can build your app,
publish it in the Chrome web
store, and have direct access to
the rapidly growing Chrome
user base, now well over
200 million users.
This is a pretty exciting
group--
a pretty large user
base already--
but pretty soon you'll be able
to grow to an even larger
audience, and deliver them
directly via the web.
Now obviously, all these new
apps that you're going to see
today are going to have
huge impact on users.
To talk about that in more
detail is Christian, our
product manager.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN STEFANSEN: Thanks,
Erik, and hi everybody.
So as Erik mentioned, Native
Client really enables
applications that just wouldn't
be possible before.
Either because they were too
performance demanding, or
simply because of the time
it would require to
rewrite these apps.
And so there's several
categories of applications
that we feel are really a
natural fit for Native Client.
The first category
is the games.
In particular, 3D accelerated
games, computationally
intensive games, and in fact,
many of the early adopters
that you're going to see here
today at the demo stations in
the back are games,
and there's a
good reason for that.
Games are a category that
traditionally push the
boundaries of what's possible
on a platform--
in this case, the
web platform.
Other categories are photo
editing, video
editing, image editing.
Imagine anything that involves
image transformations,
computationally intensive
filters,
anything along those lines.
Another category
is 3D modeling,
interactive training software--
and in fact, we have
a company that does
exactly that here today.
Another category would be
computer aided design.
Again, you have this conjunction
really of 3D
modeling and heavy
computation.
The same applies for
another category,
namely scientific computing.
So math, statistics, protein
folding, signal processing,
anything along the lines--
anything that you would classify
as heavy number
crunching would be a great
fit for Native Client.
So, of course, most of the users
are not going to care
about using Native Client, or
even know that they're using
Native Client.
What they're going to care about
is the fact they get
applications that are as feature
rich and as responsive
as desktop applications.
Yet they're synchronized across
all their machines
seamlessly, so they don't have
to install them several times.
They're also going to care
about the security.
Because Native Client is
as safe as other web
applications, you can run them,
install them, knowing
that your system is
going to be safe.
And incidentally, the install is
a frictionless process, and
you are not going to need admin
privileges on your machine.
So we've been working closely
with several early adopters of
Native Client.
And next I'd like to invite a
couple of them up here on
stage and talk about
their experience
using Native Client.
First, I am honored
and privileged to
introduce Yoichi Wada.
He is the CEO and President
of Square Enix, one of the
largest global game companies.
So please help me welcome
Yoichi Wada.
[APPLAUSE]
YOICHI WADA: Thank you very
much for inviting me to an
occasion as momentous as
today's announcement.
I can say it's a great honor
to be here with all of you.
I'm convinced that Google's
Native Client will be welcomed
worldwide as a truly innovative
technology.
Not only for the IT industry,
but for the
games industry as well.
Video games are capable of
expressing rich experiences,
and are deeply loved by players
around the globe.
However, they are also
incredibly complex
applications, and until
recently playing games
required specialized consoles
intended for that purpose.
We in the game industry have
strived to present games on
general purpose devices to bring
joy to greater numbers
of customers.
Through the [? pleasure ?]
games and the social games
played in the browser, many
people who had previously not
played games have entered the
gaming world.
But browser technology
limited us to
offering very simple products.
Google's Native Client
solves this problem.
We are releasing a port of Mini
Ninjas as our first step
with Native Client.
We have prepared a demo
of the game today.
Please give it a try, and ask
our developers about their
experience porting the game.
The feeling is something
that is
difficult to put into words.
You can't tell the difference
between playing on Native
Client and playing on
a game console.
Through this porting work, we
became convinced that Native
Client is an excellent solution
for browser gaming.
I should point out that I don't
believe that games with
console-level quality are
superior, or that such games
should be played by
all consumers.
My point is that, given that
consumers have varied tastes,
we should present a wide
variety of games.
All the first-class businesses
offer a wide selection of
choices to consumers.
With Native Client, the games
industry has been able to
realize this for
the first time.
Furthermore, what is important
about Native Client to gaming?
It's not just that you can
present a game to the same
level of quality as
a game console.
What is critical is the
fact that Chrome is,
above all, a browser.
The combination of browser and
console quality gaming will be
the impetus for social features
within these games,
to evolve far more rapidly
than has ever
been possible before.
It is incredibly exciting to be
able to work with Google in
expanding rich game experiences
around the world.
Let us begin this new
era together.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN STEFANSEN: I'm just
going to repeat one thing,
which is, go have a
look at the game.
It's on the demo stations
after this, and it's a
gorgeous game.
So, really, check it out.
Our next presenter
is Amir Rao.
He is the Studio Director
of Supergiant Games.
And he's going to talk a
little bit about their
experiences porting their
award-winning game, Bastion,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Native Client.
Everybody, Amir Rao.
AMIR RAO: I'm Amir, this
is Greg, we're
from Supergiant Games.
Supergiant Games is a small,
independent developer with
seven people.
It's located in San Francisco,
California.
We actually started in the
living room of a house in
2009, and over the course of
20 months we built Bastion,
which we released on Xbox Live
Arcade and PC this summer in
conjunction with Warner
Brothers.
And since then, people
have been asking us
what we're up to.
And actually, one of the things
we've been up to is
Bastion for Chrome.
So We're just going to show the
game running in a browser
so you can see it
for yourself.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Proper story's supposed to
start at the beginning.
Ain't so simple with this one.
Now here's a kid whose whole
world got a little twisted,
leaving him stranded on
a rock in the sky.
He gets up, sets off for the
Bastion, where everyone agreed
to go in case of trouble.
Ground forms up under his feet
as if pointing the way.
He don't stop to wonder why.
He finds his lifelong friend
just lying in the road.
Well, it's a touching reunion.
He sees what's left of
the rippling walls.
Years of work undone in an
instant in the calamity.
Is that a survivor?
No ma'am, it's a Gasfella forced
out from underground.
The kid pops him good-- fella
got a piece of him though.
And then, he falls
to his death.
I'm just fooling.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMIR RAO: So yeah.
So for those you who've played
Bastion on other platforms,
that may look familiar.
And that's kind of what's so
exciting to us about it, is
it's the same sort of rich
narrative experience that you
get on your console, or on the
PC version of the game right
inside your browser.
The other exciting thing for us
was bringing the game to a
whole new audience.
And to welcome that audience,
we added a new mode to
Bastion, which we call 'no
sweat mode.' It basically
allows you to experience the
audio and art and story of
Bastion with reduced
combat difficulty.
And also, we kind of were
relishing the technical
challenge of putting the
game on a new platform.
And with Google support
we got into a browser
in about two months.
So yeah, it's a really
exciting time for us.
Today, right after I sit down,
we're going to put our version
of Bastion right on the Chrome
web store, so you'll be able
to play it.
And then tomorrow we're headed
off to LA for the Machinima
Inside Gaming Awards
and the Spike VGAs.
We're nominated for 10
categories across both shows.
And then tomorrow we're
announcing our new DLC for
Bastion, which actually will
appear on Native Client and
all other platforms.
So it's big week for us.
Thanks a lot to Google
for having us here.
And, yeah, you can come
play the game
and talk to our engineers.
Five of our team members
are here.
CHRISTIAN STEFANSEN:
Thanks, Amir.
I've already spent quite a lot
of time playing Bastion for
testing purposes, obviously,
and so can you, apparently,
starting now.
So our next presenter is
something quite different.
I alluded to this before when
I said that you can do 3D
training in Native Client.
Our next presenter
is Neil Wadhawan.
He is the VP of Sales
and Marketing
from Heartwood Studios.
Welcome, Neil.
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL WADHAWAN: This my
colleague, Ryan Musta.
He's going to be helping
me with the demo today.
Heartwood is honored
to be here.
What we do is we support, help
our customers, enable them to
build, operate, repair, and do
maintenance, all in a 3D
interactive setting.
And we're using the Unity game
engine to develop our
applications.
We recently ported the
application to Native Client,
which the developers felt that
it was somewhat seamless.
It's still at its early stage,
but it definitely went well.
And we're going to demo an
application to you today.
Our customer, Sopogy, who is
a leading provider of solar
panels to the world, approached
us with a problem.
And their problem was, Neil, how
do we train and market our
product anywhere in the world
without having to send a field
service rep out every time
and spend that money?
So what we did at Heartwood is
we developed a 3D interactive
learning application
that solved
that problem for Sopogy.
Ryan, let's demo that.
So Ryan's going to load up a
lesson for you, and we're all
going to be able to assemble
this product after we're
done-- that's the goal, right?
And this is all, obviously,
running in the Chrome browser.
The rich fidelity is there.
We have parts here--
Ryan's going to start with the
anchor bolts, and move to the
stands, and so forth.
It's quite an in-depth lesson,
so we're not going to go
through the entire
procedure today.
But if you guys are really
curious and would like to
learn, please meet us at our
booth, and we'll teach you how
to put together this solar
panel in a 3D interactive
application.
One of the things we love about
Native Client, and being
able to port to it, is our
customers don't need to
download the Unity plug-in.
It's all native in the browser,
works seamlessly.
We're not going to get those
calls saying hey, this didn't
work, or that didn't work.
It's really nice and seamless.
It's secure.
And Ryan's going to preview the
product a little bit, show
you what it looks like after
it's been built--
that's the goal, what
it looks like.
So imagine a world where we
could all train in a 3D
interactive learning
application
that's in the browser.
For defense, military, heavy
machinery, medical.
There's countless industries
that we can serve.
So we're really excited
here at Heartwood.
We're honored to be at
Google and working
with you in this port.
We thank you for your time,
and appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN STEFANSEN: Yeah, we
are very excited about seeing
something like Heartwood Studios
come on Native Client,
because it shows the breadth
of Native Client.
As I alluded to earlier, games
are interesting, because they
really push the performance, and
then a whole lot of other
categories will come afterwards,
and this is a
great example of
that happening.
So our last presenter
is Oren Tversky.
He is the VP of Business
Development at Unity
Technologies.
And Unity, as you probably know,
is one of the biggest
game engines and editors, and
they have hundreds of
thousands of developers.
Please help me welcome
Oren Tversky.
[APPLAUSE]
OREN TVERSKY: So thank
you very much.
We're really happy
to be there.
And thanks to Neil
for the plug.
But Unity is not just used to
make solar panels, and I
apologize, I can't teach anybody
how to put together
any kind of panel.
As Christian mentioned, Unity
makes a tool chain and engine
that's used by 190,000
developers on a monthly basis.
We estimate that about 2,000
mobile games have been made
using Unity--
lots of games also
on console on PC.
And we also have our own web
plug-in, and this web plug-in
has an installed base of
about 90 million, and
this is pretty good.
And those of you who follow
gaming trends certainly know
that in-browser gaming is
an up and coming trend.
We've all seen the social games
and all that, but that's
extending now far and wide.
So this is really where kind of
a partnership with Google
around Native Client made
a lot of sense.
And we actually think this is
going to benefit developers
and consumers alike.
If we can roll the first video,
that would be great.
So this is actually the
Unity tool chain.
So this is what it actually
looks like when
you're making a game.
And as you can see, there is a
little check box that says
enable Native Client, and
then you push Go.
So our goal in working with
Google, and our goal to make
our lives easier for developers,
is really kind of
that simple.
Let's make it that easy.
The other way we think it'll
benefit developers is through
distribution and monetization.
And we're always looking for
ways to help our developers
reach new audiences and monetize
their games better.
Because after all, everybody's
got to make a living, right?
So our web plug-in has an
installed base of about 90
million, but we're really happy
to be able to add the
200 million and growing Chrome
users worldwide to that
distribution channel.
And we also think having a
monetization channel through
the Chrome web store
will help our
developers earn a nice living.
But we think the benefits will
also extend to consumers.
We think that having that
frictionless gaming
experience--
and if you can roll video
number two, please.
So this is a game by a company
called SilverTree Media based
in Palo Alto, and this
game is called Cordy.
And you can see how easy
it is to launch.
No plug-in, no dialogues,
frictionless.
We think this will make the
consumers much more likely to
play games and to spend
money in games.
The other way we think the
consumers will benefit is from
the native level performance.
And this is where we've done a
lot of work with Google to
make sure that we hit native
quality performance, so you
can really have a
beautiful gaming
experience out of the box.
And finally, we think consumers
will benefit because
there's just going to be a lot
of great games out there.
So we've got over 2,000 games
on mobile, we'd love to see
them all come to Native
Client, and
we think they will.
So why are we--
you can finish the video--
why are we here today?
Today we're announcing the
deployment of five Unity
Native Client games to
the Chrome web store.
And they are two by
SilverTree Media--
Cordy, which we showed
you, and Sleepy Jack.
Two by Exit Strategy,
Pirates of New
Horizons and Planet Buster.
And finally, one by a company
called Dedalord.
The game is called
Running Fred.
So my colleague Randy will be
over in that pod over there,
demoing all the games.
Really, our message to
developers is you should check
that Native Client box.
And to the rest of you, enjoy
the games, and I just want to
really thank Google for the
opportunity to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN STEFANSEN: Right, so
these examples really show how
Native Client can push the
boundaries of what's possible
on the web.
And on that note, we're really
excited to see several other
middleware being ported
to Native Client.
These include Unity, of course,
as you've just heard.
It includes Bullet, the physics
engine; Moai, another
game engine; FMOD and Wwise,
audio engines; and Mono which
enables you to write your app
in the entire dot net family
of languages.
And this is really exciting,
because it means the Native
Client platform is much more
accessible to the hundreds of
thousands of developers who
are already using these
middleware products.
So then the question is, well,
what's next for Native Client?
And I've got it right here.
We are adding features.
We'll be adding more APIs for
networking, in particular for
web sockets.
We're scoping out APIs
for game pads.
I'm sure a lot of people
in the audience will be
interested in that.
And we're adding more
features, like
memory mapped files.
This means that when you're
reading or writing large
files, you can get a performance
increase of orders
of magnitude, really.
What's more important is to
notice that these interfaces,
the Pepper APIs, are going to
continue to evolve in tandem
with the web platform.
And what that means is whenever
a new capability is
added to the browser, you would
expect to see JavaScript
APIs for that capability, and
Pepper APIs for the same
capability being added at
roughly the same time.
And whenever that does happen,
we're going to make sure to
have an SDK ready with the
header files, and all you
need, in the hands of developers
at the time where
that version of Chrome
is in beta channel.
So you'll have time to develop
apps that take advantage of
these features before it's
shipped into stable channel.
Another key thing for Native
Client has always been
portability.
And the portability benefits
of the system today are
already pretty compelling,
but there's more work.
In order really to be as
portable as JavaScript, we
need to eliminate any barriers
to the introduction of new
instruction sets or new
operating systems.
And to that end, David
Sehr who's in the
audience here today--
David, do you want to--
David Sehr is leading
an effort called
Portable Native Client.
And Portable Native Client will
introduce an instruction
set mutual wire format to
Native Client, while
maintaining the performance and
the security benefits that
we've already established
for the system.
And this is really important,
because this means that Native
Client is going to run, not
just on today's operating
systems, and today's instruction
set architectures,
but on the future operating
systems, and future
instruction set architectures.
So with that, I'd like to invite
Ian back on stage for a
couple of closing remarks.
Ian.
IAN ELLISON TAYLOR:
So hopefully--
there's obviously a lot we could
cover, and in the time
available we can only give you
a brief taste of what's
possible in Native Client.
But hopefully we've given you
at least a good sense of how
we've achieved on some of those
original points that I
mentioned way back
in the beginning.
How we can really push the
boundary in terms of the kinds
of applications that you can
run on the web by bringing
native-like performance.
But also maintaining the
portability and the
scalability, and the reach,
and the deployment
benefits of the web.
So taking those things together,
and these amazing
demos, and many others that we
couldn't show, hopefully that
all comes together into a
pretty compelling story.
So we at Google, of course,
are very excited about the
possibilities and what
we've seen so far.
More to the point, hopefully you
are getting excited about
what you could maybe come
up with that you
haven't seen today.
So I very much look forward to
seeing what kinds of amazing
experiences you come up with in
the weeks and months ahead,
as we continue to drive
the platform forward.
We're going to do some Q&A at
the back in about 10 seconds,
and hopefully, I think,
get to the beer.
So do stick around, ask me
questions, ask us questions,
ask our partners questions.
We've obviously got a lot more
we could be working on, and
your feedback will really help
us set the future direction
for Native Client.
With that, I'd like to thank--
wave at our audience in Asia--
I'm waving at the camera, I
actually have no idea where
the camera is so I'm just
waving vaguely.
I hope they had a good
video conference.
And, of course, thank you for
coming to Mountain View to
share in this launch.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]